but we're going to begin with ferocious
and ferocious as a word these wildfires
that are creating dangerous conditions
in parts of california
walls of flames have surrounded
buildings and prompted evacuations
across southern areas of the state the
fires are threatening multiple
communities near los angeles and san
diego including castiak which is north
of los angeles jonathan bigliotti is
there with more on the story jonathan
good morning to you i hope i said that
word right cassidy ache is that right
that is correct you pronounce it
correctly good morning to you gail we're
about a mile and a half away from where
this fire is currently active
threatening a power plant this morning
on private property the biggest concern
this morning is the heat right now it is
85 degrees this afternoon temperatures
are expected to spike to around 107
degrees
fire mapped at 4
625 acres firefighters say they don't
expect containing the root fire soon as
thousands of acres have burned in only a
few hours northwest of los angeles folks
out there are just taking a beating
filling the air with smoke the blaze has
surrounded homes burned structures and
closed highways including sections of
interstate five
with this heat wave it's very hot and
dry we saw how quickly a small ignition
can ignite and spread very rapidly at
least eight people were injured
wednesday night and hundreds of homes
have been evacuated in los angeles
county while in san diego county another
fire has burned at least four buildings
as some residents fled just craziness
firefighters left and right
the police here and there the flames are
fueled by a drought and triple digit
temperatures expected to continue
plaguing the state for the days to come
meaning more risks for heat related
problems over the weekend we're in this
for a while this is probably not going
to be the only fire that we're dealing
with here in l.a county over the next
week or so but the heat is a big factor
yeah and we are only one day into a
week-long heat wave for that reason tony
the governor has declared a state of
emergency
jonathan thank you very much appreciate
that stay safe out there